With Ken to four of Paradise.
We are now in the heaven of the Moon,
which is,
should know by now is also the,
the heavy,
the heaven of grandma.
And,
and that will show you in what way?
This is the,
the heaven of grammar,
uh,
in,
in Paradiso three,
Dante meets,
um,
to women,
uh,
the empress Constance and the irony of the name is a little bit obvious among
the inconstant spinet and Picada because the who also had the joy and the
cluster had taken the name of sister Constance.
She too,
but I was forced to leave the cluster on account of,
uh,
brothers Corso Donati's,
political maneuvers.
He wanted her married to an ally of his,
um,
uh,
with can't afford them to return to this issue,
which is the issue really,
uh,
of,
the will.
What is the will,
how can somebody else's force on me,
um,
for Co compelled me to do things that I am accountable for?
In what way am I accountable for somebody else's,
a imposition of increase this case,
his will on me.
Uh,
Dante wants to know what is the wheel here?
but there's another question that forces him to the,
another problem forces him to raise a question in canto four.
And a,
the question is,
uh,
Dante's wonder about the souls in the various stars.
They're disposed and the ranged in the various planets,
he sees some socio the moon.
So he wonders are we in Plato's,
um,
paradise is this is Plato,
right in believing that the souls at death return to the stars,
to the place of origin.
And these are the two questions that he has.
Uh,
he has to uh,
raise.
So,
uh,
the too begins with a statement that is extraordinary,
because I,
I will try to explain how the two questions are I related in what way they're
related or not just absolutely the arbitrary.
There is a,
a certain link between them.
Uh,
but the biggie the,
they can't afford begins in a very,
with,
uh,
at other strange formulation about the,
the,
the nature of the will and the freedom of the will.
So since that's what cons,
uh,
that,
that's what the car does situation had forced Dante to raise.
What is the will is somebody else's,
will uh,
forcing me to do something.
Am I still responsible for it at has to clarify what the wheel is.
So he starts with a statement that seems to suggest that the will is in Ert.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
a poem,
that the will cannot really make decisions.
First of all,
the will,
uh,
given the opportunity to choose between two contradictory objects of desire
can't quite move one way or the other.
You need the intellect.
That's the argument that makes the will take,
make a decision.
We'll force the world to make a decision.
And this is the way he starts between two foods are equal distance and equally
tempting if free men would die of hunger before he brought her either to his
lips
and [inaudible] would stand between the cravings of two fears.
Wolves in equal fear of both.
This seems to be a kind of will that joins human beings and animals says that
paralyzes us.
The choices paralyzes the will so that maybe when we speak about freedom of the
will,
we are not speaking,
read about freedom of the will.
We speaking about the freedom of the will in the intellect.
It's the intellect that has to be free.
So that's,
that's really the argument.
Uh,
so would the hounds then between two dose,
therefore this is the sed,
three imagers that introduced Dante's own doubts and perplexities.
He has two questions.
Each of them seems come more compelling than the other.
It does not know what to ask first.
So we'll the hound stand between two dose.
Therefore,
if I kept silence,
urged equally by my doubts and other blame or commend myself since it was of
necessity,
I was silent,
but my desire was painted on my face and with it,
my question far more warmly than in plain words.
So Dante's indeed talking about the limitations of the will,
not that they will is this is an a verus position.
It's a position of a radical interpretation of Aristotle that the will is in
earth.
That you always need some kind of the power of the intellect to make you decide.
The intellect cannot move,
but the intellect and made the will move so that the statement has to be
understood as one of the hierarchy between intellect and will that the argument
and our continuous Beatrice did this,
the Daniel when he appeased the wrath of Nebraska,
Donna's uh,
that made him cruelly and just,
and she said,
I see where,
how one desire and then other droll day sort of their eagerness itself binds
itself and does not good breath.
That's the reasons.
If the right,
we'll a newers on what ground does another's violence lesson the measure of my
dessert,
how can it be that?
Because the who was forced by somebody else's will,
it seems to appear in the lowest,
the lowest birth of beatitudes.
She's on the moon.
Why should she be so undeserving of,
of,
of a closer intimacy to God?
Um,
so that's a curious question.
Also,
it gives the perplexity that their soul seems to return to the stars in
agreement with Plato's teaching.
These are the questions that press equally on thy will first.
Then I shall deal with the one which is more poison in it.
And it's very interesting,
first of all,
the language of poison.
But the,
the,
this idea of what is dangerous of the two questions is not the question about
the will that the question,
which is more dangerous is the question that deals with representation.
Where is the mode of appearance of the souls in heaven?
And why should representation do the sols in habit stars?
Are they showing themselves forth?
Here it is a make believe that they are here.
It's a fiction.
It's pyrotechnics if you wish.
And once the night is over,
then the soles return to the probe proper abode,
which may or may not be visible to the pilgrim.
Is this a theatrical performance and why?
If this is a theater and it is,
why should that be a question that has more poison in it?
Why,
what,
what's so dangerous about representation?
That's really the argument that as Dante puts it forth here at the beginning,
at least,
and then she goes on for,
so let's discuss it and then we'll as we discuss it,
we tried to understand,
uh,
the question why this is representation are such,
such a hard issue.
And she says not he have the set of him.
This is lines Paradiso four lines 28.
There is most made one with God the the in the choir of angels,
those who are closest to God,
not Moses,
Samuel or whichever John Doe will none the apostle or the visionary this year,
not Mary herself have their set seed in other heaven from this spirit that have
now appeared to the,
this is the poetics of paradise by the way,
that we are really confronted with.
How do the sols show themselves forth to the pilgrim?
What is the mode of Dante's representation in paradise from the spirits?
I have an iPad nor for there being have more years of few words,
but all make fair.
The first circle hold sweet life in different measure is they feel more or less
the eternal breath.
These,
which we're seeing here and,
uh,
on the moon are,
are,
have shown themselves here.
Not that this fear is allotted to them,
but in sign of the Hemley rang that is least exalted.
They have,
uh,
they enjoy a lower degree of beatitude than the other souls.
So they just appear here for your benefit.
In other words,
the whole of Paradise,
that representational paradise is fictional.
And once the pilgrim disappears,
so will the soles vanish.
They will return into the bosom of Abraham in according to biblical accounts.
Uh,
it is necessarily now that explains why they need for this allegorize is
allegorical,
our lego article,
language,
allegorical representation.
It isn't necessary to speak to us,
to your faculty,
since only from sense perception.
Does it grasp that which then makes fit for the intellect.
So the whole of paradise is literally and accommodation of Veritas of realities
that far exceed the powers of our mind.
And now it's,
it's,
uh,
a condescension.
The soul's condescend to show themselves down to us.
So Dante,
first of all,
has been talking about the limitations of the will.
Now he's talking about the limitations of the intellect.
So these are the two issues that join and intellectually speaking that the
candle for and each seems to need the other,
uh,
and be made stronger in the light of the other.
And 90 goes on explaining this,
uh,
this mode of representation which he says is not only true for paradise,
but it's true for scripture.
It's true for all the iconography of the churches.
And that's where he says it's necessarily to speak.
Um,
for this reason,
scripture condescends in the,
in the literal sense of the word and etymologically,
it comes down to us that accommodates itself to our limited faculties.
Condescends to your capacity and the tributes,
hands and feet to God having and other meaning.
That's the definition of an allegory.
The Bible in deed speaks of the hand of God.
It's an anthropomorphic trope.
The guard has no feet and has no hand.
And what it means,
it's something else.
It means the power of God or The Majesty of God,
the feet of God,
et Cetera,
or with the feet.
But now with this,
there is a language of representation.
Even in the,
that in many ways also rises Dante's own juice of representation.
Is this clear?
So far?
Good.
There's no,
no,
no real,
no real difficulty.
This,
this issue.
Um,
and then you're going to tell,
take this for this reason is that that um,
and holy church,
but that's what happens in the Bible.
It talks about the feet of God.
We read about the feet have gotten a heck of a holy church represents to you
with human aspect angels that have no human form.
Gabriel and Michael and the other who made top it whole again and now the
distinction between the metaphor,
the platonic metaphor and the biblical allegory.
What ty meals argues about the souls.
It's not like that.
What we see here for when he says he seems to hold for truth,
that's already one,
one,
one basic difference.
It is.
It seems that what's what for the Bible is a metaphor becomes true in the
context of the time ears.
He says,
Plato says the soul returns to its own staff from which he believes it to have
been separated when nature gave it four form.
He literalize is the idea of the souls returning,
returned to the stars by perhaps this view is other than his words express Emma
have a meaning not to be despised if he means to return to the return to this
wheels of the honor and blame of the influence.
If by returning to the stars,
it seems to imply that at the fall of this soles is also go through the various
stains of the planet.
And,
and,
and then the return to this,
the,
the planets from which they originated his Bob perhaps strikes are certain
truth.
The principal is understood once misled almost the whole world.
So that went astray,
naming them Jupiter and mercury,
Mars,
et cetera.
So Dante's,
um,
uh,
then,
then Beatrice says,
[inaudible] the other doubt.
This is the language of doubt.
Intellectual doubts,
which are always part of truth for tanties the truth that generates a truth that
generates doubt because their mind is,
is that exactly the way he described the will both restless.
Both need a nourishment,
constant nourishment.
So this had intellectual doubts.
The other doubt that troubles the,
the has less poison.
He repeats this idea,
less danger.
He hasn't said yet why the world of representation is dangerous.
And actually he lives at,
at,
at this because it's mischief could not lead the away from me.
The other justice that other justice appears unjust in the eyes of maltose is
evidence of faith.
And we'll go back and we'll go in a moment,
but let me stay with,
uh,
with the first question that Beatrice as a resolve,
for the pilgrim and for us.
She's,
she's distinguishing between the theology,
the biblical theology,
and let's call it the philosophical allegory,
a biblical allegory and philosophical allegory.
The language of metaphor in the Bible as the language of Metaphor,
truth in,
uh,
in Plato,
and Dan himself clearly is here legitimizing his own use of metaphor.
The whole port is indeed a metaphorical journey,
um,
whereby Dante is both simultaneously a biblical and also philosophical.
He,
he's,
he's finding and trying to decide on the common ground,
the metaphorical language that the Bible and Plato,
we'll use an and therefore himself.
But why is representation so dangerous that has so much poison in it.
And Beatrice twice goes back to that image.
And I think that the answer is this,
that representation has the power to cancel or erase the world of references,
which it represents.
The presentation has the power to um,
to make appearances.
The only reality Simulacra the only reality that we manage to see,
and it literally covers it eclipses or references.
That's what makes a representation so dangerous.
It has,
uh,
we,
we are,
uh,
by virtue of the representation,
we ended up in a kind of quandary in the predicament of believing that that's
all that it is.
That what that which is visible is the only real thing and invest they
appearance,
invest that simulacrum with the salt of value that it normally does not have
because it actually,
it points nobody that doesn't have because it points for Dante to essence is
behind it.
We have seen here the souls,
the soul.
So I wrote this is not the real home for the spirits.
The real home is somewhere else.
We may make the mistake Dante made of believing that the souls actually live in
on the moon and therefore that we are in a platonic other world.
In another world where there's holes,
go back to it.
The journey of Dante is the journey between images and testing of what this
images may mean.
Finding out whether this in behind this images,
there is some kind of substance,
some kind of reality than politically removed between the two words and things,
images or representations and,
and appearances and the world of essences and,
and,
and tries to join the two of them.
So you understand why representation is the key issue here.
Uh,
let me also add that this,
this course on allegory justifies,
it gives you an idea why Dante has been that this is the heaven of grammar.
Since the allegorical discourse is a grammatical issue is remember that have
been talking about how each planet seems to deploy,
uh,
well,
one of the liberal arts.
But this is the,
the reason why we can connect to our grammar and,
uh,
and,
and the more,
the other problem the Dante raises in Canto for is the question of the will.
And,
uh,
and he,
he,
that's an easier issue because he just goes on distinguishing between what we
call a conditional will,
the will,
what we will whenever we are beset by circumstances that forced on us some
resolutions and then absolute will the absolute will of the martyrs of those who
are,
for instance,
who are unwavering and faltering in the confrontation with,
uh,
with particular experiences.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the souls of this,
of a,
of Bacardi and Costanza,
they were really,
uh,
exist.
Exercising their own conditional will,
not their absolute well.
So it's an interesting distinction and we live it at that.
Um,
we moved downstairs to the heaven of the Canto six,
the heaven of dialectics of Mercury.
A why Mercury's the,
why should he be the God.
Uh,
this is the planet mercury,
but the God are tied with dialectics or logic,
which are really not exactly the same thing,
but Dante,
that's use them interchangeably.
Hermes is of course the,
that God known the psychopomp,
the one who brings,
you know,
that the part,
the mythology,
the God who brings messages to,
to the world,
the,
the realm of,
of,
of shades,
the roam of the dead,
the care is the souls to hades.
That's one of the,
the,
the ideas of,
uh,
the resonances of mercury.
Now there is also others that mercury is the God who are the bearer of laws,
the better of messages of the gods to human beings,
the bearer of laws.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the god of the marketplace though doesn't seem to have much,
much impact.
That particular relevance,
Particular Resonance Of the myth to this,
uh,
this cancer and this,
the logic,
what is the,
what are they electives?
Gotta with understand where they electrics is one of the arts of the trivium.
And it is the art by which I mean to which,
which provides really a method.
That's the way it's defined.
It provides a method to distinguish between truth and false foods.
Uh,
so it's,
it's,
uh,
let's see how this is going to be present.
Interestingly enough,
Dante's really talking about laws here.
And actually I'm here.
He meets the great theorist,
uh,
the,
the emperor Justinian who is responsible and who is usually acknowledged as the
one who favored the reorganization of Roman law in,
uh,
in BizOps hill,
which is where he lived.
Um,
okay.
And,
and not only needs to Gio stadium,
but he also tells the story of Rome.
So it's a cantor about history.
And the,
the,
the idea is what's the rationality of Roman history?
Is there in rationality to it?
If dialectics is also the,
the,
uh,
the science of,
the power to distinguish between false hood and truths,
it's also irrational,
uh,
irrational,
discipline.
The discipline that follows the rule of reasonable means of which one can go on
making those distinctions.
So the question becomes,
what is the rationality of the Roman empire were kind of,
of,
of justice,
uh,
was there in it.
So Lowe's and at the same word,
the logos,
uh,
seems to be ruling the unfolding of this Canto.
And it begins with the story of Constantine,
who we have met before for the famous as we are accountable for the donation of
Constantine.
The you may know,
uh,
it's the famous alienation of imperial property to the church for Constantine's
as Constantine's token of gratitude to the Pope Silvester,
uh,
who had cured him of leprosy.
And this gave rise to a famous,
uh,
much debated,
donation,
uh,
which Dante dismisses.
So Dante views as nothing,
less transgressive,
nothing less tragic and disruptive of the older of the world.
Then for instance,
Adam's sin.
It's really they hey ma,
cosmic propulsion,
uh,
because it mixes together the sacred and the profane.
It makes the pope at temporal ruler and,
and,
and that is the ultimate degradation of the moral of the moral authority,
the exercise of moral authority from Dante's viewpoints.
So this is,
uh,
this is the illusion to the duration,
but the initial to a donation he is taken into.
Now the,
uh,
the reference to Constantine has a slightly different,
sense after Constantine,
he says,
turn back the Eagle against the courts of heaven.
We had followed behind him of old that took Lavinia to wife for 200 years and
more the bird of God,
Eagle,
the emblem of the empire remained on the bounds of Europe near the mountains
from which it first came forth and their rule the world under the shadow of the
sacred wings passing from hand to hand.
And so changing came into mine.
I was Caesar,
Oh,
the imperial,
uh,
title.
The imperial persona has disappeared.
And now he appears as I am Justinian here once again,
the use of that,
that,
that shift of verbs from the past to the president.
And now I'm in the eternal life.
I am myself.
I just sit.
And who by we'll have the primal love,
which moves me removed from the laws.
What it was superfluous and uh,
and vain made the distinction.
This is really a definition of dialectics made.
The distinction between the purpose and very negative was essential.
Uh,
let me,
uh,
give a gloss on this first paragraph.
The illusion is to Constantine's moving.
That's the other sense.
I,
it all don't donation,
but moving the seat of the empire from Rome to the east designs Hume.
Okay.
And this is seen as the violation of a metaphor of is the paradigm of history,
which was called Translab Theo
translatable in Perry.
Uh,
what is this?
What does it mean?
It's the idea of you'd all day in the Middle Ages or speak of translation all
the time.
The translation of studies,
uh,
translation of the empire,
the idea that the whole of history follows a pattern,
a movement from east to west,
and therefore the,
uh,
the,
the duration of history is patterned on the movement of the sun from east to
west.
And with the idea that when the empire reaches the most western point,
the western most point of,
uh,
of the map,
that's going to be also the end of history.
It's the end of the day,
the sunset and the end of history.
Okay.
So constantly by turning back the,
this translation of this movement,
that's what it means to transport a transfer,
um,
uh,
of,
of the empire actually delays the apocalyptic.
They knew more the end of time.
And the end of the day.
And for Dante,
this is a major violation of the economy of history.
So it begins with this idea of a violation or tragic violation of history
brought about by uh,
constantly.
And the illusion of course is the other illusion is 20 years with whom the
empire had started after the fall of Troy had started to go west westward and
then constantly reverses all of this.
You understand,
by the way,
this is,
I mean,
uh,
on,
on election day,
I really should mention this,
that the whole idea of manifest destiny is based on this principle of the
Translock Feo imparity cause the empire moves west word all the time.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we are now therefore,
in the proper commpass,
uh,
of,
of history,
so to speak.
Uh,
okay.
So constantly with Levenia who went backwards,
a vineyard,
why for the the,
um,
of an years.
Uh,
I must also indicate to you at this could become,
in case you're still looking for a topic,
this is one of the first times that Dante starts using this geographical
coordinates,
the geographical description.
Europe.
He has really not done that in neither an inferno,
no improve the Tori,
but now Europe becomes an increased concern of his whatever historical
information may have of it now.
And it's,
it's uh,
uh,
this is,
the Europe and the east and none who we'll be talking about the,
the,
the borders of Europe in the West.
There's a kind of idea of,
of,
of a Europe that has his asking what kind of messages can come from Europe,
which is still valid,
legitimate today.
This is a sort of incredible questions that he will ask,
um,
in distinguishes between Rome and Europe in the sense that Rome,
he will say in a political track that he writes that the history of Rome,
it's different from the history of Europe.
13,
20,
he writes this kind of thing.
13,
18,
maybe he writes this threat and the em,
the,
the emblem for Europe's a firm,
sorry for rooms.
Distinctiveness is to be found in any,
his experience of meringue.
Three wives,
he may risk crazy as we are here from the Aeneid.
He may arrest Deitel though.
It's a marriage of convenience.
So to speak,
but it's a marriage.
And um,
and then he may raise Levenia and 90 goes on to explain the three ways the three
wives he marries are one from Asia,
one from Africa,
and one from Europe.
So that an he,
his whole experience,
whole history encompasses what are the time was thought of as universality,
the three known continents in a wing of which only Europe,
Europe is only a part.
Okay.
So keep that in mind.
I will talk more about this metaphor as it appears now.
This is the context of Europe.
So Justinian and the reference to uh,
his,
um,
his reorganization of the Roman code known as they Justinian code.
And then now we have a history of the empire from the emperor.
We have what seems to be a celebration of the Roman Empire.
This is Canto six,
therefore like Canto six of inferno and Canto six of Purgatorio.
The focus is political.
It's not just the city or Italy.
Now it's the whole empire.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but what begins as a celebration of the empire in effect,
turns out to be a critique of the ideology of the empire.
The Myth,
the mythological reading that we can find in Augustine's confessions.
Uh,
Dante follows two models here and there are two models that are contradictory
with each other and they sort of presentation of Canto six.
We have the Virginia and model of the Roman Empire,
which is really a celebration of its origins with an years,
uh,
with palace,
the whole account told and in the Aeneid and with the vision of what is to come.
But then there is around the fifth century,
the Augustine writes in the city of God,
a fierce critique of the empire.
The empire has fallen,
the claims by the time Augusta writes,
the claims of the eternity of the empire turn out to be hollow.
And two,
Augustan the empire is nothing less than another one of,
uh,
another episode in the long history of a predatory,
politics of imperial possessions and violence.
It.
The Roman Empire is an empire is no better than all the other empires that have
grown,
been that had long vantage and vanquished.
Okay,
so this is the,
these are the two models that Dante's evoking and in fact the very language,
just to give you an idea,
at one point,
Dante,
we'll say it's down knowest aligns 35 and 40 that it is made,
it's stay.
The Eagle is the story is told through the vicissitudes of this emblem of the
symbolic emram the Eagle for 300 years or more till the last still for its sake,
the three Razzi you may,
you may know a little bit of Roman history.
That curiosity,
who fight it out with the duel between the three brothers and the other three
brothers,
the three,
four,
two,
the three and you know,
it was what it did under seven kings,
the story of the seven kings from the wrongs and Sebine women to the wool of
Lucrece conquering the neighboring people around about,
these are all phrases that come straight out of Augustine's city of God and they
are used as cases had exemplifying the libido of power.
It Rome erotic stories of erotic violence,
Lucretia who has been raped.
And the story of this Hubba and women who have been kidnapped by the,
the,
uh,
the bands of Romulus and Remus and there are other outlaws.
There's this idea that the empire was,
was born in,
uh,
in a condition of outlaws.
So damp is using the perspective of Augustan because have Gustin had used these
examples to them,
the empire and its own,
uh,
Barand policies,
but at the same time,
all the rest is really Virgilian.
This is the moment when virgin and the gas didn't really disagree from each
other.
Why does Dante do this?
What is this?
What is the reason for bringing together two contradictory sources of historical
thought?
What is,
what,
what's the idea of poetic mythology of Rome is in favor of the empire or is he
against the empire?
Is Izzy with a Gaston or is he with,
um,
actually with Virgil when one thing is clear that our Gustin who loves Virginia
of course,
uh,
decides that this is,
that the empire is an abandoned a reality in his own history,
it's already falling,
falling apart.
And,
uh,
he has no use for this in his theological vision.
The question that he raises is,
what do I care who governs me?
Provided this is here,
that they do not make me sin.
The reality is an internalized reality.
That reality is that one,
which is in the interior life of all of us and what our empires,
if not great thefts,
he will go on dismissing all of this.
He a Roman citizen at,
at,
at the end,
at the twilight of the empire as the sixth century or show.
Uh,
so what is,
what does this done to stand in between them?
So he continues,
I'll have an answer.
I hope he continues for now.
We don't,
he doesn't tell us yet.
A Thou knowest did,
was born,
but it lustrous Romans against Bruner's.
Um,
uh,
it brought her,
brought low the pride of the Arabs who behind Hannibal past the Alpine crags
from which Po,
uh,
follow stuff.
The follows under it.
Uh,
it's huge.
You in Pohnpei triumph then near the time,
etc. Uh,
this will continue into the violation of the Rubicon by Caesar.
And,
uh,
it,
and then it goes home with Charlemagne line 95 and following.
And now let me just read the passage,
the last passage now the cons judge of such men as I accused before,
um,
and over their offenses,
which are the costs of all your drills.
They weren't opposes to the public standards,
the yellow leaders and the other claims,
the lilies are friends and the other claims that for the party so that it's hard
to see which offense,
the more let the Gibber liens the can't all of a sudden becomes a vocative seems
to turn into a replica of inferno,
six of the civil war between wealth.
And he believes it starts as a celebration and then call me some of the empire
and its role in history,
right?
This westward movement of,
uh,
of,
of tor,
then apocalyptic conclusion.
And now all of a sudden it goes back to let the Berlin's carry on the odds and
the,
another standard for of this is always a bad photo.
Who serves it from justice and let,
not this new child star,
I get it with a Welsh,
but let him feel its clause,
which have torn the hide from a greater lion many time before now have the
children wept for the father's fault and let him look thing God will change arms
for uh,
their Lilly's.
So what is this?
It starts with the empire ends up with the civil war and the civil war is really
the perspective from which Dante can take this double view on the history of the
empire,
where Dante can really stand up to the opposite,
the,
the stance of Augustan and the stance of,
uh,
of,
of a god Oh of Virgil.
And that when he's really seems to be saying,
I think is this yes,
gas,
then you are right.
That the empire is really a negative force in,
has been a negative hope force in history.
And that the reality is the,
as you say,
and internalize the reality of our own,
the overall piece,
the kind of internal will that we can,
we managed to plicate,
uh,
at the same time he says for Virgil,
but you're also right in,
okay.
Your valorization of the empire.
Okay.
Because the empire has brought about some older and laws into the world.
So that's the argument.
And yet
against her Godson,
he says,
okay,
if there were no laws and there were no loss of the empire,
then there would be no way of sheltering each and every one was in case of the
civil war.
What makes the argument for the necessity of the empire is the reality of the
civil war,
which really demands the presence of x transcendence institution that will
manage to contain the violence of human beings.
So you can see he had agrees with Augusta and disagrees with Augusta.
He agrees with Virgil and disagrees with Virgil.
Virgil leaves no room for the internal.
The,
in that experiences of Christians,
uh,
on the other hand are Gastin leaves no room for the necessity of an outside
structure that could,
uh,
older the appetites of human beings that can comes to an end with a,
a little bit of an auditorium,
autobiographical,
uh,
portrait or autobiographical picture.
Um,
uh,
this is now the emperor who praises a counselor,
a counselor who has fallen into disgrace within this mall.
The same per shines to the light of Romeo Romeoville nerve.
It province,
our core tier who had the role of a exactly.
It will being the,
the counselor for the prince was great and noble work was ill,
rewarded by the province house.
We'll rotate against him.
They don't have the laugh and indeed he takes a new road.
Who makes of another and others we'll doing a wrong to himself.
Raymond Bellenger had four daughters,
each of them Mcqueen,
uh,
Romeo man of low birth in the stranger did this for him and when crafty tongues
moved him to call to account this just men who rendered him seven and five for
10,
Romeo left,
the poor left.
They're poor and old.
And if the world knew the hothead,
begging this bread by morsels matches,
it traces him,
it would praise him more.
It is an oblique,
uh,
representation of Dante himself who has to end up begging and poverty for a more
so as he says,
out of the,
uh,
the,
the selfishness of the political powers.
But the,
the other final question,
I think it's underlies this whole whole candle that has to be raised is what is
the relationship between dialectics and this representation of history?
Why should Dante connect the two wine,
the heaven of logic,
let's say?
Does he have to talk about history?
Um,
and I think that the idea is that the history itself,
um,
I think that he's,
this is an encomium that ends up being not quite an unmitigated encomium.
Uh,
it's also a critique of the empire.
That there is a reason within the empire.
And yet this reason doesn't quite justify all that the empire has perpetrated in
history.
And I think from this perspective,
Dante's also
forcing on us some perplexities about the nature of logic as an instrument of
power is one that could justify or possible powers.
So they say also a critique of a of dialectics.
As much as that is a critique of uh,
of history and we skip hold together cause I think it's a little bit more
evidence and you can,
if you read on your own,
uh,
you can see Canto eight and nine.
They have rhetoric and I'm a rhetoric and love.
They're very nine especially very clear.
We move instead to the heaven of the sun,
which is a little bit 10,
11 and 12.
Uh,
I don't know that I'd be able to finish all of Canto 10,
but I want to start the discussion here.
We are in the heaven of the sun,
which is the,
the heaven of they're having a very thematic numbers and he had done,
he goes on talking about one model of the trinity that I will describe to you in
a moment.
Uh,
Dantin counters the wise spirits,
the spirits of a,
in fact,
we are going to see very soon,
there are two wheels of saints to Garland's representatives,
two gallons of old men who hold themselves by the hand dancing around around the
sun.
It is the dance of wisdom.
If it was at this,
that the,
the,
you could call it,
you could also refer to it as a kind of a reorganization of the encyclopedia.
You may remember that I used this metaphor at the beginning of the cloud over
the course.
Uh,
this idea that the divine comedy is,
tries to repurposing a new circle of knowledge,
the way in which things can really be known.
And,
and,
and the encyclopedia means,
uh,
the journey education is in a circle as you,
the mind moves around through the various arts and sciences.
That's,
that's,
that's how you learn.
That's you return to which you already knew from a different viewpoint.
And you see things,
uh,
things are new and it's a,
but it's the heaven of this.
And let me just go on a little bit with,
um,
with the cantor and then we'll,
we'll try to bring out some of the,
the issues of,
uh,
Canto 10 looking on his son with the love,
which the one and the other eternally breathe forth at primal in the ineffable
power made with such holder.
All that revolves in mind.
Oh,
space that he contemplates.
It cannot be a taste of him.
He beans with a trinitarian representation.
The father,
the son,
joined together by the breadth of love the street.
That was the idea of,
of the trinity,
which is a unity.
That's the paradox of arithmetic,
of this theological arithmetic,
uh,
is an image of fecundity.
Uh,
God is being an image of love is generative of itself,
uh,
within his own,
unity.
And then Dante turns to us,
and that's the last time I believe that he turns to us readers and he tells us
to be stargazers.
That's all.
So he's saying lifted that ice with me.
Then reader to the lofty wheels,
directing them on that part where the one motion strikes the other.
And for a poet to take their pleasure in the arts or the master who's also loves
it in his heart,
that his eyes never leaves it.
See how from there the circle branches will bleakly that beat bears the planets
to satisfy the world which calls for them.
He,
that makes her eyes to an intersection of the ecliptic,
the equate the cosmic equator and the ecliptic.
We ecliptic being a term that describes the journal,
an annual movement of the sun.
So when they meet the pope,
that crossing,
uh,
that that directs our eyes there.
If they attract,
we're not a slant,
etc. Stay now reader on the bench thinking over this or which there has the
foretaste and national have much delight before they are weary,
have set before thee,
not feed herself for the theme of which I make describes Ben to itself or my
care.
Why does Dantes thing over the trinity and the in the Heaven of the Sun?
This is the simple question that we should ask.
I have a passage that I want to read to you.
It's taken from was I think this is the,
it's taken from the,
the sooner that you're nice is you may have heard of from Dante,
we'll mention it's a misses,
a mystic.
Um,
um,
uh,
the,
and he writes in the,
in the,
on the divine names he writes about how the mystical hierarchy,
uh,
and,
and this will explain to you a little bit of the what is Dante's
at this point,
send me mystical theologists having a mystical idea of the trinity.
Um,
this idea that knowledge has to be love.
He begins with an idea of the trinity bound by love and that knowledge has to be
loved.
Let me read this passage and the,
maybe we can go from there.
It's,
I call it a solar theology.
Uh,
uh,
that is to say,
Eh,
the theology of the sun.
I feel not about the sandbox.
Solar,
the theologists would be understood as the life of the sun itself.
As You sun,
let me read this passage.
Think this is from a six,
nine,
three beyond the divine names and following thing of how it is with the sun.
It exercises no rational process,
no act of choice and yet,
but the very fact of its existence,
it gives light to whatever is able to partake of it,
slide in its own way.
So it is with a good,
a classical comparison.
They of course are the sun with a good in the Republic of protagonists in the
Indian needs and so on.
So this was a good existing far above the sun and archetype,
far superior to its doe image.
It sends the race of his undivided goodness to everything with the capacity such
as this may be to receive it such beings,
oh,
the presence and that unequipped and that diminished lives to this race.
They abide in the goodness of God and draw from it the foundation of what they
are.
They're coherence there,
vigilance,
their home,
they're longing for the good,
makes them what they are and confers on them.
They will be shaped by what they yearn for.
They exemplified goodness,
and this is the law of God requires of them.
They share with us below them the good gifts which have come their way.
Uh,
I call it a solar is theology in the sense of dump.
He is the,
I think,
thinking of a theology as sub.
Oh God.
The Trinity,
it giving as a fountain,
not the Aristotelian or,
um,
they'll mistake or Augustinian idea of causality.
You know,
we think of God as the one who imparts it calls or emotion to things or a
beginning.
And then you have a teleology you have effect.
The idea of the trinity here is one of,
uh,
an inexhaustible source that keeps giving and it gives tool and we're all part
of this gift.
This is the idea.
I think that Dante is getting this,
what I call the solar,
a theology from a mystical text.
We'll call the sooner the United States.
Again,
not that he is a mistake,
but he lead appears as one who is,
uh,
behind the rationalist facade of his thinking is aware of the depth,
and other ways of thinking,
which are,
which are not those of the rational,
rational route.
Um,
and let me just,
uh,
go from,
describe even more here.
What,
what happens with,
uh,
with this can't or 10,
um,
uh,
now,
Dante goes on seeing this too.
Um,
uh,
this tool or this tool,
garlands of,
uh,
scenes.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is,
let me read 'em.
Um,
he meets Aquinas and let me read from this passage where he,
uh,
Aquinas will go on giving a naming the first encyclopedic this movement of
sages,
uh,
lines 100 and following where he says,
I was of the limbs of the holy flock,
that Dominic on the path where there's good fattening if they do not stray,
he,
that his next beside me on the right was my brother and master Albert of Cologne
and I'm Thomas Aquinas.
If there was,
we'd us informed of all the rest,
fall off to my words with denies going round the blessed wreath.
The next frame comes from the smile of Grecian who served Canon Law and civil
law,
the one and the other courts so well that gives pleasure in paradise.
The other who next the dorms have choir was Peter,
who like the poor widow offered his treasure to the holy,
the holy church.
Then the fifth light,
which is the most beautiful among us breeds from such a love that all the world
below hungers for news of it within it is the lofty mind too,
which was given wisdom so deep.
The truth be true.
They never rose a second of such a vision.
It's Solomon described through circumlocution of the fifth light and the fifth
flight because in numerical symbolism,
five stands for their natural number,
which is to say that Dante casts very difficult proposition.
Solomon is being naturally perfect,
having a kind of perfection of intellect.
It's a dangerous proposition.
In fact,
Dante,
we'll go home.
Aquinas will go on and kind of 14 says,
look,
let me just explain what I said before because it's not quite true because they
say the,
the virtual intellectual verge of Solomon consists in the fact that he knew what
to ask for when we had to govern his people.
He was the perfect king does.
He knew what to ask.
You understand why this has to be a dangerous idea.
If you believe that there is a perfection of the intellect in within the
natural,
imminent sphere,
older where we live,
then it means that there is no need for revelation.
There is no need for intermediaries,
no need for redemption.
If the,
if,
if nature,
the natural intellect is capable of ascending as it is claimed here for Solomon,
then the whole apparatus would collapse.
Dante will not believe it.
And Aquinas will go back as a dramatically actually in canto 13.
St.
Let me just,
uh,
explain myself.
Besides,
it is the light of the candle,
which below in the flesh was farthest,
uh,
et cetera.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
in this,
Augustan and then skip the body from which he was driven less below in chilled
outro.
This is brief use.
Uh,
he came from martyrdom and exile to his peace.
See flaming beyond the growing breadth of Isidore bead Richard of some victor
who in contemplation was more than mainline one 32.
Then read this line because I think it's a little bit more interesting in the
Italian than it is in English.
In contemplation.
It was more than men.
Uh,
Ysidora Veda,
it did Ricardo,
I consider our full puke of euro.
The word done pay users is not contemplation is consideration and it's a key
word for vantage was consideration means the etymologies that of moving with the
stars.
This is if the mind they said it's the most perfect when it imitates the
circulation and circularity of the stars.
Consider uh,
it's also like desire by the way.
Um,
this one from whom they look returns to me is the light of his spirit to him in
his grave thought that seemed slow in coming.
It is the eternal light to CGIAR who lecturing the street of Straw demonstrated
in videos.
Choose the last one that Aquinas points out in this and this,
this circulation of wise spirit is one of so called headache by the name of
seizure of broadband who was an a virus.
It was condemned for his various whatever knowledge and whatever canonized
knowledge we may have for Dante.
It includes figures who had been judged and worthy of knowledge or heretical or
wrong,
and now they are retrieved.
So the idea of knowledge is one that keeps changing.
The idea of the canner of knowledge keeps always expanding and it including
voices that had been rejected.
Let me tell you more about this representation of seizure of broadband.
You understand his anniversaries and we do know how to Stantec.
What about other than just saying he's here,
how does he go about justifying his salvation?
A cantor 10 from this point of view is retrospectively one that sheds light on
Canto television fare.
No where we also saw you remember the verus and the epicureans.
Uh,
we though Cavalcanti those who believe that the mind,
uh,
that love of knowledge never interact with each other,
that the,
the,
that their mind,
uh,
goes,
the rationalities is darkened in them,
but inclusions or the passions,
right.
You remember.
And that their mind is one that receives ideas from the outside.
All that,
that notion of,
uh,
of,
both the inertia of the wheel and the divisions within the mind itself.
Nantha now is,
is,
is correcting some of those views.
So let's look a little bit at this metaphors in Canto 10.
This one from whom they look returns to me is that I to a spirit to whom in his
grave,
Stoltz death seemed low,
slow in coming.
He was killed by the way,
by a madman.
And Dante writes a song.
It's about him in,
um,
I'm 12,
uh,
81 or so.
It is the turn,
the light of seizure.
So we know that he's saved who lecturing in the street of stroke.
They demonstrated invidious true.
Don't pick,
give the address of this man.
He lectured a word that,
uh,
has,
has a certain value in the university language that use the lexicon of the time.
Lecturing is an activity that implies glossing just his,
the glow Seta of Aristo too.
But he's tells us where he lived in the shoe,
in the,
in the street of Straw in Paris,
a strict at now is cold,
by the way,
the,
the holder.
Wow.
But it's now called the who?
Dante.
Knowing the clearly the Persians are mindful of this passage.
Uh,
[inaudible] is placing seizure on the road,
on the way he's giving us his,
uh,
his,
his address.
But he's telling us that he's thinking takes place while he's on the road.
You all know,
you all know that philosophy is always understanding itself as a journey and
method and exodus,
right?
Uh,
per amenities or Aquinas who thinks about the five ways to reach the ultimate
truths about God.
Here for Dante is a philosopher,
is on the way to a theological certainty,
theological truths and theological knowledge.
And he demonstrated in videos,
truths.
The Italian is see low GI Joe made syllogisms out of or,
or exp demonstrate the rational.
He demonstrated in values,
truths.
What are this invidious truths in videos?
Truth,
I'm not sure that,
uh,
all the translators would agree in truths have to be understood.
The gemological and this is the canter where Isidore of Seville is presently.
The,
the,
is the Roseville being the arch etymologist of the Middle Ages.
And Dante is showing how to,
we can play with a tomato trees.
You know,
he said all severe is the one who believed that the whole of knowledge that Oh,
we're all,
we know,
the higher the,
the,
uh,
the commpass of all knowledge can really be arrived at through Etymology,
arising language,
language,
the atem on of language.
The origin of words will give us an access to the nature of reality.
So language becomes a way of knowing the world.
Dantin Dodgers in the same activity,
calling the truths that CGIAR pursued invidious which etymologically means those
things,
those truths that cannot be demonstrated,
those truths that can not be seen.
Philosophy appears as a nod of speculation that takes us on the way to a truth
that it cannot fight,
have access tool.
What are these drills that seizure or broadband salt access to,
um,
the,
the immortality of the soul.
There's no way he would have known or even discovered that I just daughter is
very doubtful about the individual immortality of the soul in the treatise on
the soul.
He tied to consider,
to view a,
to,
to decide about the origin of the world.
Cgiar believed that the universities,
uh,
another one of those and the most trouble believes that the university is
eternal,
right?
And this is an argument that so medieval thinkers and theologians engaged them,
either Rosen,
the one side and Aquinas who maintains a philosophically,
you really can believe in show that the universe is really,
uh,
is eternal.
But out of faith you can go on believing in creation.
Creational things have a beginning because it's dumb.
You don't think that things have a beginning,
then there's never a possibility of,
of,
of uh,
uh,
allowing for giving some ground and,
and,
and rooting the idea of your freedom,
your innovations,
that possibilities,
things can be different from you,
from what they were before.
And so on.
The reason why Dante rescues seizure of broadband is a way for him though
ultimately of thinking and making this thing that whatever we believe that is
knowledge.
It's never definite.
And it's whole is we are literally on the way and rethinking it and making it
all the time.
Uh,
an object of our own self critique.
This is not the only thing.
The only place where a dentist rethinking himself very soon,
uh,
at around the notion of the Trinity Bonaventure we have to change his mind about
a main,
a figure that I have mentioned before,
joke him more flora in the next,
canto the idea with the jaw acoustic interpretation of history.
So he will,
he will,
we are going to have a kind to 11 balancing off,
uh,
Canto Canto 10.
And then it ends the cantons.
They're like a clock or an extraordinary image.
It's an image of time now.
But what I have to say is that you probably do not know that [inaudible]
mechanical clouds the way we still see them.
Where the,
the,
a recent technological invention in the late 13th century,
which Dante is absorbing here,
uh,
then like a clock that calls us at the hour when the bride of God rises to sing
Matins to the bride room that he may lover when one part draws or drives another
sounding the chime with notes.
So sweet that they were loaded.
Spirit swells with love.
So I saw,
uh,
the glorious,
we'll move and render voice to voice with Harmon in sweetness that cannot be
known.
But there were a joy becomes,
uh,
it turned out,
Dante is describing this songs of the eternal,
uh,
of the,
the,
the blessed souls in erotic,
in the robotic,
uh,
erotic terms.
So that what seems to be a can't have pure knowledge ultimately becomes a love
song to,
and this is the,
um,
the whole trajectory of Canto 10.
Let me stop here and see if there are some questions about this three,
three candles,
which I'll be glad to,
to answer that a little bit abstract,
but I think that they respond to genuine,
uh,
general interesting historical problems.
At least
the question of allegory of at the beginning.
And just give you a kind of a quick cruise you may have about what we said we
can't afford.
You have two issues.
So you have the issue of allegory and the issue of the will,
um,
where Dante goes on,
uh,
explaining the mode of representation in paradise as a mode of accommodation to
our limited faculty.
And he thinks that this is really the mode of representation throughout the
Bible,
the iconography of the church,
that poem,
uh,
et Cetera,
which is a way therefore of talking about allegory in it's slightly different
form from where from the the,
the way he spoke of it in a,
as you remember when I spoke of it,
but he was a forced allowing us to do that in Canto nine of inferno.
What did we,
we had been talking about the allegory of poets are liberal theologians now
there is no question that I think that there is really is there is no intrinsic
difference between the two modes.
You remember that I used to talk about the undergird of theologians as being an
allegory where the literal level is true and the allegory of poets as one in
which the literal level is a fiction.
Now I'm saying that both of them for Dante have a kind of metaphorical basis.
Okay.
Both the,
the and the relationship between the metaphor and the truth is pets of course
it's,
it's sorta certainly the language of a very similitude if not absolutely the
truth.
And then the two,
the other issue about,
uh,
the will,
the limitations of the will,
um,
the conditional and absolute well when we can't come to Ken to six paradise,
Dante shifts gear all together and talks about history.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the framework of the empire trying to do,
is it providential,
I call it what is the nationality of the empire?
But the accurate,
the real issue is,
is there such a thing as a,
probably then charity of the empire are which she had maintained in elsewhere in
the poem.
And certainly in the,
in the text of Monarchia,
uh,
Dante come crudes now seems to,
to have to explore,
give an apology for his belief in the empire,
uh,
by agreeing with and,
and siding with Virgil.
But at the same time,
giving a critique of the empire that acknowledging Augustan but managers to
criticize both,
both Augustan and up for different reasons and virtual had not seen the whole
truth.
Uh,
virtual,
uh,
can go on into an unabashed Lao that CEO laudatory statements about the empire
are Gastin can go on damning the empire,
but a gas,
it does not understand that if a and w within the context of the civil war,
uh,
where,
you know,
the realities were Corso can turn against his sister because where the world can
go against the good balance,
where your own brother can be your enemy.
That's,
that's really what it's about.
Uh,
then you do need some kind of law.
You read an outside world,
uh,
and outside institution that can guarantee and protect,
the,
uh,
yourself,
the claim,
uh,
that salvation is only then the interiority of the soul are,
which is a Gaston's claim is not really sufficient for someone who is him as
Dante was involved in the public sphere and the public life.
Uh,
I think that these are the two most important moments in Canton.
10.
Dante is moving beyond the,
the,
it's,
it's a poetic break now takes place.
He literally moves us beyond the,
the sunlight,
the daylight of the ordinary,
natural daylight.
We moving into a world now,
which is his own,
and Dante starts raising the issue of,
uh,
knowledge
as if to say that a new knowledge and new way of thinking now is necessary.
Once you move beyond the ordinary boundaries of,
uh,
of the universe,
you gotta you,
you start asking yourself,
what kind of knowledge do I need here?
And he's rethinking therefore the,
the,
the whole relationship between truth or knowledge and narrower heresies and
knowledge,
uh,
the canonical certainties that Aquinas would have who now make significantly
enough,
I mistake about the faith of solid on and a and seizure of broadband.
So that,
that seems to be the,
the argument that is running,
uh,
in this,
this cantors he is forcing on us a different way of thinking and a different way
of thinking begins with a redefinition of nothing less than the trinity.
Uh,
no.
The idea of causality note the idea of efficiency.
No cows.
They Fiekens.
That's the way God is defined by Aquinas.
That's the way that Augusta Guston defines how is he lights a treatise on the
trinity.
Uh,
with the idea of God is called Saturday,
Dante ads doesn't exclude the others.
It would be inconceivable that something has imponderable is the trailer.
They could just have one formula to account for it.
But he adds on to it that first definition of the trinity as a unity of love and
the unity of fecundity,
which I think is a mystical definition,
the idea of God,
the idea of creation is wonderful.
Participation of the creatures,
the idea of God as being the source,
the inexhaustible source of light.
Oh,
and not just efficiency and not just a TV,
all of the movement,
et Cetera.
And we shall see the implications of this if we go.
Yes.
I was just wondering why is it such a problem for Dante to imagine like a
perfect natural intellect and Solomon because isn't sort of auditory started the
perfection of the wealth through Virgil's into in Bridgeville reason.
And so why,
why is it a dangerous proposition to say that a man could have perfect
intellect,
right.
The question,
very good question is why does Dante find it so difficult to acknowledge the
perfection of Solomon's intellect?
Uh,
when after all in him fed and improve authority,
we have had,
um,
some accounts or how they will,
is moved by the intellect and perfected by the intellect.
Am I paraphrasing your batch of repeating?
But you said,
I think,
but accurately.
Um,
it's a very good question.
It's a little complicated problem.
And,
and uh,
in fact that I think that what you have,
uh,
um,
you,
you have to keep in mind how Dante talks about Solomon.
They said people on Earth,
I saw anxious was here.
This was one of the most incredibly debated a pro is he saved his Solomon saved
versus the wisest it all.
That's what the Bible tells us.
He's the wisest.
And we believe that by the Middle Ages argument,
we believe the Bible.
So he's the wisest,
but he was also known as being the most lecturers of kings.
Tall,
big solution for Dante.
Ah,
forget about that.
He's,
he's really,
uh,
the wises so he's saved.
So that solves that particular issue of the relationship,
love and knowledge.
And I think that's a crucial point in for the way you are stating the issue
because you're stating how in and improve that or you have the will directed and
reorganized,
but the intellect,
uh,
so you see there must be some kind of relationship between will and intellect.
Dante,
he says they will was really,
uh,
was,
was a little bit,
was chaotic,
was dissolved as well.
So we have only to judge him in terms of this majestic intellectual he has.
In fact,
he was the most perfect of figures since Adam was created in the garden,
you know?
Okay.
So that's,
that's the first thing.
But now let me come to the crux of the matter here.
If you believe that he had a intellect,
which was absolutely perfect,
perfectly intellect,
then what you really say,
and this is the context of knowledge and my thesis is the Greeks call it,
okay,
the,
my thesis,
the word mathematics.
And if you believe that,
then you're really saying that loss of is the way to come to the truth.
You see what I'm saying?
And the philosophies that were to come to the truth,
you don't really need theology.
You really have to start thinking of theology as some kind of vulgar,
vulgar,
philosophize earners and some kind of,
uh,
the poetry for,
for the Masters for instance,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
a material elite like view that keeps,
are creeping up into,
in,
in the ways of thinking about theology and,
uh,
and,
and philosophy.
And if you believe that that philosophy is the mode,
in fact,
now we have a correction of the philosophers immediately after with the presence
of seizure.
Because of course,
she,
the ambivalence CGIAR is justified and saved because his mind was a searching
mind.
He's on the road,
he's a true philosopher.
He,
it's the method I was describing.
Logic is a method that the Greek word that means way,
uh,
it's the,
the root,
uh,
you know,
the philosophies around the rule,
the processes on the way around there,
all the say they all this sea of the soul,
that's really,
we call it Dante says,
exodus taste is a,
an exodus clearly countering the idea of the philosophical root.
There's another,
another story.
Another way of looking at journeys has certainly evolved in a journey,
a journey of the heart and the journey of the mind at the same time.
So once you,
you,
you go on a seizure is on the,
so,
but there is,
there was no perfection.
He tried to demonstrate and look at the paradox in reduce this to say truths
that cannot be seen.
I appealed to the etymology of invidious many translations and uh,
uh,
they say I'm welcomed fruits,
you know,
I don't know what kind of translations actually I like my saint Clair who says
invidious truths,
but many others translate that word in videos as,
as unwelcome or the,
the truths that made him a bis scorn and hated by others.
Because you know,
the,
the jealousy of philosophers,
uh,
it's a little bit in the background.
He lost his life.
Uh,
he was killed because of that.
but instead he is in input shoot of truths,
which is,
you know,
the aim of philosophy of are all investigations,
but philosophical investigations but cannot be demonstrated that cannot be seen.
So there is a limitation of the philosophical road of the road of philosophy and
indirectly the limitation of Solomon's perfect claim of,
he never claimed it,
but the,
the,
that he had a perfect intellect and in fact,
our,
who realizes what he has said,
he says,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the Wa the wisdom of Solomon has to be viewed in his prudence for asking God
that he'd been given the absolute,
uh,
knowledge in the government of his people.
So it's a limited form of knowledge,
but that was perfect.
You see,
it's,
maybe it strikes you as sophistry.
Um,
but I enjoy that.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you so much.